this video is brought to you by Wix
[Applause]
what's up my fellow Illuminati Spheeris
chills Jared here if you don't spend
your late nights exploring the deep
crevices of the Internet you may have
missed the growing number of people
committed to proving that the earth is
flat flat earthers have increasingly
been the subject of scorn and ridicule
as their numbers grow on YouTube and
social media and while rehashing debates
that were concluded centuries ago is fun
I'm not exactly here to prove that the
earth is round
instead I want to talk about how flatter
a tourism speaks to another crisis
namely how do we know that we know [ __ ]
we're currently living in a crisis of
knowing our trust in the people who are
supposed to know things has rapidly
eroded do scientists know things do
physicians know things do government
agencies what about the hit Facebook
page mom's united against vaccines /
GMOs slash Harry Potter do they know
things and while we may laugh at the
routine slam dunking of people we don't
agree with it's missing the point a bit
because our society is undergoing a
problem that is caused by and affects
all of us so let's get real nerdy about
the philosophy of science in this
wisecrack edition on flat earthers but
before Jared gets into that a quick word
from me mark Schroeder aka garyx
wormuloid
here to talk about this video sponsor
wicks now as some of you know I'm not
just an alien I'm also an actor and a
great way for me to get my work seen is
with a killer website so that's why I
decided to make a free awesome looking
site with Wix and it was so simple all I
had to do was tell Wix that I was making
a website for myself tell them the kind
of website I wanted and whether or not
I'd ever made a website before spoiler
alert I hadn't but it was so simple and
so easy before I knew it the site
builder was asking my style my design
preferences I was dragging and dropping
photos and videos right into my website
it was so simple to do and right now you
can get started for free yourself all
you got to do is go to wix.com and slash
wisecrack or click the link in the
description below okay Jared back to you
for anyone who isn't caught up on
flattered if this discussion is
motivated by the recent Netflix
documentary behind the curve but don't
worry you don't really need to have
watched it
Flattr theories are a little bit
scattered in their beliefs
is it a dome or an infinite plane how
far away is the Sun what causes an
eclipse etc but their unified in the
idea that the earth as sphere is
deliberate misinformation propagated by
some shadowy agents including but not
limited to NASA the governments the
world and probably after this video
wisecrack one prominent model featured
in behind the curve is that the earth is
a flat plane enclosed in a dome called a
firmament 70% of them believe that this
is covered by some sort of dome a
concept that dates back at least to the
biblical story of Genesis the Sun
travels in circles above the earth not
millions of miles away as understood by
scientists but thousands and it's not
really a huge ball of fire radiating
light in all directions but along with
the moon is more like a flashlight
illuminating parts of the globe
so how does one get to the point where
they reject the round earth well you ask
questions like why don't planes go to or
pass Antarctica
why haven't will companies set up shop
on Antarctica why are there only
composite images of the earth and not
whole images now your first thought
maybe these people are complete idiots
why are you wasting your time on this
but behind the curve complicates this
understanding we see smart critical
humans who say things like this I became
a flat earth or because I tried to
debunk Flat Earth or this I mean I think
that the scientific method is the best
way to get from the truth or a guy who's
smart and talented enough to make a
badass motorcycle out of wood which hey
I couldn't do if I tried Flat Earth and
other debates about otherwise accepted
scientific fact bring out a much larger
problem our understanding of science is
terrible and I'm not complaining that
people don't remember the laws of
thermodynamics or that I still don't
understand how magnets work water fire
in Magnus how do they work I'm talking
about the philosophy of science so what
is the philosophy of science its
philosophy obviously that asks questions
like how do we distinguish science from
non science and with that how should we
weigh evidence when testing a hypothesis
what kind of evidence is acceptable
basically how do we know if we know [ __ ]
you might remember learning the
scientific method and that's part of it
but it barely scratches the surface
there are a lot of philosophies of
science and I'm not here to tell you
what the right model is it's important
to understand that all of these
frameworks have strengths and weaknesses
and to us it's our general ignorance of
how science works that allows for the
abuse of scientific language we see in
things like Flat Earth so to get a
better understanding of how flat
earthers can use the language of science
and evidence to persuade people let's go
back in time and the early 1900's there
was a scientific dr. imposed by a group
known as logical positivists called
verification ISM this model essentially
posits that science is something that
can be verified if it can't be verified
it ain't science so philosophical
statements like the meaning of life is
be excellent to each other not science
because you know how would you verify
that let's start with a very simple
example if I were to say this Swan is
white you could say hey it looks white
to me I could pass it around and you
could also verify it is white so awesome
we're using our senses in a way that can
be replicated by others so it's been
verified and as such this Swan is white
could be considered a meaningful
scientific statement in this model if
you want to verify that the earth is
round or flat one way would be to go up
in space and look at it how do you know
it's a globe well it's because you saw
this it's not like you've been up there
and your Jetsons car nobody's got a
spaceship and in this way flat earthers
seem to at least allude to this basic
idea of verification but how do you
verify a statement like all swans are
white which Europeans considered to be
the case before the 1600s let's say you
and others have encountered thousands of
swans and every single one was white is
this evidence enough well not quite for
the verification as' and this was a huge
problem for them when it came to
universal statements like all swans are
white all hid
sirs drink PBR all mass exerts
gravitational pull you can never truly
verify I mean what if there's a
theoretical hipster out there who shuns
PBR in favor of Heineken Heineken yes or
a Black Swan which by the way was
discovered by Europeans in Australia in
the 1690s now flat-earthers may latch
onto this logic and say well we haven't
verified the earth is round with our
eyes but if we try to apply this as a
doctrine for science that all
individuals have to see things with our
eyes it'd be pretty limiting if there's
a an event like a I'll just use Boston
bombing again I'm not going to believe
any of those events are real and less
than myself I get my leg blown up but as
far as are all swans are white problem
this was a pretty big crisis for
verification ISM until a philosopher
named Karl Popper proposed a now-famous
solution rather than focus on
verification scientists should rather
focus on falsification for popper good
science is coming up with a hypothesis
and then trying really hard to prove it
wrong if you can't you can be confident
in your hypothesis say that all swans
are white but that doesn't mean it won't
get proven wrong when say we discover a
Black Swan or two in ensuing decades if
a statement could not theoretically be
falsified pitting science so the meaning
of life is to be excellent to each other
is still not science so if I thought the
earth was flat I might design several
experiments which could prove it wasn't
flat and if my hypothesis that the earth
isn't flat is correct then it's probably
time to abandon Flat Earth importantly
proving that the earth is not flat does
not prove that it is round nor does
proving that the earth is not round
prove that it is flat what if it's a a
donut balanced on a giant turtle now
we're going to talk a lot about popper
here but I should probably mention that
there are other approaches too for
instance the probabilistic approach of
someone like Thomas Bayes who would do
some math to give you a probability for
something to be true so a statement like
I'm 90% confident that eating a five
Tide Pods will kill you now you might be
wondering are flat-earthers good
falsification as' we test everything you
might say hey they're giving contrary
evidence there's an experiment in the
1800's flight patterns and our eyes
right out there that's
Seattle you shouldn't be able to see it
there should be hundreds of feet of
curvature between us and them
we should barely be able to see the tops
of those buildings but there's a few
problems but let's focus on two one
their evidence is usually bad and two a
big part of falsification is trying to
prove your own theory wrong not proving
someone else wrong to prove yourself
right so for the first one let's look at
a darling experiment for flat earthers
the Bedford level experiment Samuel
Robottom wanted to see if a boat would
actually dip below the horizon as it
would on a globe and it didn't so round
earth disproved not really experiment
design and science is really hard one of
the hardest things can be controlling
what are called confounding variables ie
external stuff that is going to screw up
your results and for the Bedford level
experiment that confounding variable was
atmospheric refraction the bending of
light caused by different air densities
so you design a new experiment to
control for that variable and you can
test that which Alfred Russel Wallace a
famous scientist did and that experiment
which uses objects that are higher up to
control for refraction provided evidence
that the earth was round it's also more
or less the experiment this guy does in
the documentary which brings us to the
second point and an actually interesting
question for science and falsification
ISM scientists raising contrary evidence
is important in the scientific community
but flat earthers don't just want to
falsify the round earth they want to
prove a flat earth and that statement
that the earth is flat as popper would
argue also needs to be tested we have
constantly to criticize our own seals
our own interpretations but can it let's
look how this plays out with this guy in
his laser gyroscope and this guy with
his flashlights in the case of the
gyroscope a drifting gyroscope would
suggest that the earth is not flat which
turns out to be the case we found that
we were picking up a drift
a 15-degree per hour drift and with the
flashlight experiment a light source
that did not align with his holes
correctly would also suggest that the
earth is not flat which also happened
interesting so time to drop your
previous hypothesis and come up with a
new one to falsify right well not quite
the problem with most woowoo whether
it's anti-vaxxers flat earthers
creationists and so on is that if you
ask them what evidence would you require
to renounce this theory the answer is it
probably doesn't exist I won't change my
mind on anything regardless of the facts
that are set out before me as behind the
curve highlights even evidence to the
contrary isn't quite enough instead of
moving on laser gyroscope guy is
convinced that heavenly energies are
messing with his data and the flashlight
guy had some kind of reason to ignore
the results of his experiment proposing
a theory that can be falsified doesn't
seem to be the name of the game for Wu
this point is made so ironically clear
when Patricia steer a flat earther
realizes that claims that she works for
the CIA can never be sufficiently
disproven to satisfy her critics the
thing about all of these things is I
can't prove any of it wrong believe it
or not this kind of mental gymnastics
that we see with our Flat Earth
experimenters is a basic problem in a
ton of science not just flat earthers
because one compelling criticism of
falsification ISM is that tests and
hypotheses don't exist in vacuums they
exist in larger systematized theories if
we consider science to simply be the
process of trying to falsify various
claims we can see the limits of this
model with Newton's physics who I think
we can all agree is an ogee scientist
Newton came up with his laws of motion
his theory of gravity he also invented
calculus and they all worked together
armed with newton's theories scientists
made predictions about how the solar
system worked figuring out celestial
orbits with a combination of observation
and math building on his theories
scientists made new claims and tested
those claims and then those claims would
become the basis for other tests yes
science now where's the problem well
Newton's model predicted Mercury's orbit
would do one thing
and then it did not that so does this
falsify Newton's model and if so should
we all just drop it and move on
of course he also thought he could turn
metal into gold and died eating mercury
making him yet another stupid [ __ ] well
in contrast to falsification ISM
physicist Thomas Kuhn understands
science as working in paradigms so for
Newton's physics keep on poking holes in
it but don't grow the baby out with the
bathwater until your inquiries point to
some bigger badder paradigm that comes
around and you do everything Newton's
model can do but better in this case
that bigger badder paradigm was
Einstein's relativity and so for Newton
instead of mercury proving him wrong
scientists just tweaked the model for as
long as they could Newton's laws could
accurately predict so much not just the
movement of most celestial bodies but
basic locomotion engineering and so much
more so certainly it wouldn't be good to
throw it all away to address this issue
some people just said hey there's
another planet that would make Mercury's
orbit weird and Newton is still right
system tweaked and in a perverse way
this is kind of how flat earthers
operate while you might say the
gyroscope drifted flat earthers own in
reality they just tweak the model in
this case by positing the existence of
heavenly energies but does that make
flat earthers real scientists
unfortunately no because these tweaks
should also get subjected to experiments
so if you're going to say heavenly
energies are a confounding variable for
your gyroscope experiment you better
find evidence of heavenly energies and
if you can't find any maybe you should
ask is my model wrong
maybe I should test a new hypothesis
that the earth is round according to
thomas kuhn this is how science works
you have scientists working off a bunch
of unquestioned assumptions that gravity
works like this motion works like this
and then contrary evidence starts piling
up the system isn't overturned until
someone comes along and suggests a new
foundation to work off of and then
scientists kind of duke it out over who
is right Einstein's model for instance
can account for Mercury's weird orbit
and a bunch of other stuff while being
able to make all the good predictions
that Newton's model
already did [ __ ] calls this a paradigm
shift progress and science is built on
people arguing over the truth before a
new paradigm becomes the consensus not
necessarily capital T truths okay so our
flat earthers the Einsteins in this
story pointing to contrary evidence for
a full paradigm shift we're not just
winning we're crushing them well not
quite I don't know how people believe
that you can think of Einstein coming
along and saying my model can do
everything yours can do but better
because it did and the Flat Earth model
helped build long bridges a functioning
Global Positioning System navigate
airplanes launch missiles across
continents transmit TV to your house by
a satellite or do literally any of the
hundreds if not thousands of things that
are predicated on a round earth nope and
yet they still persist which brings us
to something a little outside the realm
of science and into a pressing problem
for the modern world jacking off YouTube
overlords please don't do monetize this
because we're just talking about just
asking questions in off it's an epidemic
in almost every modern political or
internet debate it goes like this
heroin probably not I don't want my
lunch money going to drugs who's taking
these drugs what would be the point I'd
ask a question in the case of Mark
sergeant's massively popular Flat Earth
Clues it's one big circle Jack well it
may take five seconds to raise the
question why aren't all companies
drilling in Antarctica it could take you
a good five minutes to learn that in
1959 scientists convinced a bunch of
countries that they shouldn't bring all
their bowls to the most remote and wild
place on earth a few minutes later you
might learn these scientists argue that
Antarctica should be open to discovery
for people all over the world in five
more minutes
you might also learn that in 1991 to
clarify things
they signed another treaty explicitly
stating that to preserve Antarctica's
environment there can be no commercial
activity for 50 years also as it turns
out extracting stuff from the most
remote place on earth is extremely
expensive and kind of dangerous the
original question why don't companies
drill in Antarctica is like arguing a
national park doesn't exist because
obviously oil companies would be all up
on that if it did and look that took me
all that time to answer one single
question another great example is flight
patterns where a flat earther might ask
questions like why didn't they go here
in which case you would have to explain
how projecting a sphere onto a flat
image to store its images which was the
cool thing we learned when we all
discovered that Greenland is not as big
as Africa so why didn't they go this
other way because it would take longer
or there's not enough demand for a
direct flight flat earthers may say
they're winning the debate against round
earthers but this is more of a statement
on how profoundly bad public debates can
be if in science the burden of proof
rests on you to prove your hypothesis
jacking off functions by dumping the
burden of proof on you with about eight
million questions and by the time I've
answered your question about why aren't
there flights over the South Pole you're
ready to raise five more simple
questions how do we reconcile this with
the fact that like this guy they're a
natural inquisitive and rejection of
normals could be beneficial to science
if they were more psychically literate
science is built on asking questions one
of the primary problems is that
questions aren't meant to exclusively
start a debate it's not I win and you
lose
rather questions seek to start
conversations that build consensus like
saying hey Mercury's doing some weird
you know over here let's all figure this
out instead the questions posed by flat
earthers are meant to prove the earth is
flat
by drawing doubt on the round earth
these kinds of arguments can be
appealing because on the surface leaving
questions unanswered looks like you're
wrong or hiding something so instead of
dumping on flat earthers it's important
for us to understand how science is done
how scientific consensus is made and
even be critical of when science is done
badly for instance there's a ton of
psychology studies out there that can't
be replicated and that is bad science
but it's probably not a conspiracy all
right there's one more thing worth
answering why why are flat earthers a
thing there are a lot of ways to account
for flat earthers and other conspiracy
theories some psychologists have
suggested that conspiracy theories
appeal to people who either feel
powerless or insignificant in society
and yeah we get that in a world where
literally everything is outside of your
control cracking the real answer to who
shot JFK is appealing it can make it
feel like the world is
rational and predictable and that seems
to be the basic appeal of flatterer
that were not a tiny blue marble
drifting in the cosmos but a special
little terrarium that's the center of
the universe but unfortunately for this
lady you're looking at all different
possibilities and making it come
together and work science isn't about
putting together random facts like
pieces of a puzzle flat earthers speak
to a larger crisis of trust going on in
our society and rather than relegating
it to some corner of the internet with
chuck-e-cheese truthers we should
understand it as a larger crisis of the
erosion of faith and expertise of all
kinds and this isn't harmless as we can
see with this guy they want people dumb
blind deaf to the truth so they can
inject you with their vaccines and their
public schooling it's not just that we
need more scientists to understand
genetics and evolution to cure disease
but that this line of conspiratorial
thinking can make almost anything
possible from claiming a woman named
Patricia works for the CIA because the
last three letters of her name to
sending death threats to people who you
think are crisis actors and that's not
even to talk about the almost extinct
diseases that are making a comeback
and killing people thanks Internet it's
not that we should have blind faith in
the Talking Heads of science but
understand the conventions and practices
that got them to their conclusion was
their experiment designed well what
level of confidence do they ascribe to
their predictions does contrary evidence
debunk a model or is it inevitable when
studying things as complicated as say
quantum physics or climate so what do
you think do we need better education on
how science works or am i collecting my
check from NASA well it's actually wicks
you can build your own website for free
by clicking the link in the description
and as always thanks for watching guys
peace
[Music]